les âges régulier de la cigarette
constitue un des facteurs essentiels du
cancer du poumon c'est du moins ce qu'a
établi le rapport publié par la
commission d' enquête qui a été chargé
par le gouvernement américain justement
le faire une enquête sur les méfaits du
tabac ce que vous pensez que la
publication de cette enquête risque
d'entraîner une diminution de ventes de
cigares et non je ne pense pas pas
jusqu'à présent personnellement je fume
et je n'y crois pas et parmi tous vos
clients
est ce que certaines personnes vont
permettre d'en choisir le tabac de pipe
ou le cigare puisque c'est des produits
qui sont moins grasse origine ça c'est à
voir
le filtre a beaucoup pris mais par la
suite on verra peut-être davantage de
pipe dit que le tabac est moins nocif
je ne crois pas beaucoup que ça ferait
beaucoup de torts à la clientèle parce
que déjà très souvent à vue on a lu des
choses pareilles sur le journal et les
gens ne disent jamais aussi je file
malgaches verbal cancéreux là c'est pas
là je peux rien dire tu connais pas et
de toute façon vous n'avez jamais
entendu dire est qu'un vrai fumeurs
abandonne pour quelques raisons que ce
soit depuis enrichi quand même même s'il
quand même s'il croit que j'aime
beaucoup cet article là non je ne pense
pas que cet article là puisse influencer
le groupe humain le risque d'avalanche
09 lancera pas je ne pense pas non
on n'avait jamais entendu dire un gros
fumeur je vais abandonner parce que le
non j'aime les regarde le cancer non non
sûrement pas non voilà la vie du vendeur
ou la vie du consommateur maintenant
c'est à dire du fumeur ou de la fumée
si vous apprenez que tabac que la
cigarette donne le cancer
est-ce que vous arrêteriez de fait mais
bon je ne suis pas parce que branché
grand fumeuses et vous croyez que rien
ne peut arrêter le grand fumeur de
filmer enfin même le risque d'être
malade je sais pas mais en tous les cas
mon beau frère il se met vraiment pas
beaucoup peut-être trois cigarettes par
jour et à l'âge de 42 ans et les banques
d'un cancer généralisé
si on vous annonçait que la cigarette
donne le cancer est ce que vous verrez
fériés de fumée non je prends pas vous
pensez que rien ne peut empêcher un
corner
je crois pas même pas leur islam à la
donne pas si vous lisiez colisage
régulier de la cigarette contribue à
donner le cas c est ce que vous
continueriez quand même un film i robot
toute façon je suis plus conscient du
problème mais enfin je crois que je fume
une amende est vraiment alors je pense
qu'il ya un moyen quand même de faire
attention de pas trop et gérés de
manière à ne pas porter justement ce
mardi non non non vous avez c'est la
pitite vous pensez que rien ne peut
empêcher en numéraire de fumer même pas
le risque d'avoir une maladie on sera
peut-être si vous mettez des plus beaux
ça vous fait quand même réfléchir
ah oui est ce que vous pensez qu'un
fumeur on ne peut pas s'arrêter de fumer
ce n'est pas possible c'est très
difficile même essayé j'ai essayé même
quand on est malade peut-être que si on
est menacée ont pas plu et forcée mais
c'est pas sûr c'est pas vrai est-ce que
vous arrêteriez de fumée ont jamais je
fume beaucoup même si vous risquez
d'avoir le cancer du tout une bonne
santé reste bonne santé et c'est fou
mais jusqu'à soda vous savez je suis 59
ans et je fume toujours de presse deux
paquets et vous compté jusqu'à sept ans
aux cheveux chez le var au chant
intitulé soul et de bilan sur l'a43 pour
l'un des deux villas vous savez avec 4
et 15 ans
je vais attaquer les gosses
[Musique]